the guy who's yet to allow a run all
year is pitching tonight
and that's anthony stefani goes up
against adam frazier
that's cracked deep to right center
field
and clear the deck cannonball coming
for adam frazier and it's one
nothing just like that he loves the
lead-off home run doesn't he he's ready
to go
bang a first run given up by diesel
funny
this ballpark rick and here comes
josh bell that about covered
on swinging his belt as the pirates out
in front one nothing here's colin moran
moran trying to get it going again and
lines this deep to center field
colin moran clears the deck don't you
know
number six well way way over 400 feet
yeah
off speed pitch that was down two
nothing pirates a little greeting here
for
diesel funny first couple of runs he's
allowed
this season trevor williams should be
very confident going into this game
against the club that he is
dominated so two up two down for joey
votto
and a little check swing roller up first
and right of the bag
and all vado can do is slump his
shoulders and trevor williams at it
again with some
soft contact gets through the reds light
up one two three four
polanco for the pirates to lead off good
for a home run tonight
oh did he get it deep to right
and how about a cup of coffee yeah i
guess he is good for a home run tonight
three nothing pirates they tried to go
buy him upstairs i mean it's
top of the zone he got just enough of
that ball you know location on the
on the bat eric gonzalez that's cracked
fastball driven deep to left off the top
of the wall by
gonzales he's gonna have to hustle into
second he does
a double for gonzo almost gonzo
here's stallings the number nine hitter
and up the middle pass the drawn in
infield it's almost the other way up the
middle
four nothing now we'll see what bell can
do here the base is loaded
well chopped up third and that'll get
through a base hit
stallings is in here comes frazier to
the plate
he will score it's a two-run baltimore
chop
through the left side pirates are up six
to nothing
first and second with one out for moran
who homered lasted
now moran with a base hit to center
field
no doubt cora will wave home the runner
and
newman will score it is seven nothing
reynolds walks the pirates have reloaded
the bases
3-1 pitch ball four a bases loaded walk
and
eight runs across gonzales
chopped and they will get
a second out but the pirates will get a
ninth run
first and third nobody out once more a
payoff pitch to nick sinzell and a
looper into left center field will fall
for a base hit so sinzell knocks in a
run
and the reds are on the board here in
the second inning
so one out double by winker
evan senzel lifts one into right field
which is hit
pretty well and senzel has gone yard
into right field a two-run home run
i'm not even sure that nick senzel
thought this ball was going out i mean
look how that ball comes off the bat
almost straight up in the air but this
ballpark
could take care of a lot of slumps
inherits runners in first and second
with the pirates up 9-3
in the fifth inning in lorenzen's pitch
this ball is hammered into the left
in a leaping spectacular play
by shogo akiyama
he took away at least a double and a
couple of the runs
shogo little show time
[Applause]
that one aligner and show go again oh my
is he putting on a show in left field
here
tonight and again lorenzo you talked
about
the jeff ruby steak a little bit earlier
i don't know if shogo eats red meat but
he'd have a pile of it in front of him
if you're a lorenzo
galvez and freddie galvez puts a charge
into one way back left field
and wow way back there for galvez that's
his fourth home run and he's homer now
in back-to-back games
nick senzel the run scoring single his
first time up had a
two-run home run to right field in the
fourth inning
and a liner down into the corner by
schenzel
one run gonna score winker on his way to
third they're gonna hold him there
no sense in taking that chance single
homer
double he has driven in four he's back
keaney kelleh first action of the season
oh he got him to chase in the dirt and
raise the jolly roger
the pirates score two in the first seven
in the second
and win it 9-6